as a kid did you
what did you aspire to do obviously you
aspired to be a skater you left
and went to europe did you do you have a
plan
yeah i mean i think early on it was like
really ambitious just sort of locked in
on like i'm going to be a professional
skateboarder and move to california
right that was like the plan from like
13 on and i think i just got so
committed and got so good and
that you know i was validated right so
even though it was a dream i kept
getting validated i would get sponsored
then then i would but you said your
first sponsorship was what your first
sponsorship was not money no no no not
real money no no you're just being like
you get free product you know what i
mean you gotta understand when i turned
pro i still
made only the boards that i sold and i
only sold one board my first year of
being a pro skateboarder in december and
i got a check for two dollars you know
wow i was guaranteed a thousand dollars
to a month to move to california when i
was 17
and i felt like i had won the lottery it
was like you are you wait wait wait wait
what
guaranteed a thousand a month i'm out of
here
moved to san diego
rich
rich when i got there were you able to
live at a thousand dollars a month yeah
i mean look to give you more context to
my mother's sort of point of view of
this whole thing i moved in with these
four girls and when i told my mom oh wow
all right i got like hey i got this
amazingly cheap apartment i'm moving in
with these four girls she's like oh my
god you're gonna have aids
i swear to god first reaction right i'm
like aids
[Laughter]
what are we talking about here yeah i
mean like that was uh you know who are
these four girls i was actually a a
friend of mine's that was a pro
skateboarder sister in her room her
sister and all her roommates had an
extra room so that's who i ended up
moving out do you know these girls today
oh man i haven't seen him in years i
wouldn't i probably wouldn't even
recognize him if i uh even saw him and
we're talking you know if i was 17 so 30
years ago man you don't remember anybody
from 30 years ago your mother you've
known for 47. i i mean look and i i i
still got to put together some of those
memories you know it's it's but yeah no
i don't i you know i kind of have a
little bit but i almost look at like my
i've done so much and i do so much that
i have to specifically focus
on retaining moments that i know i want
to carry forever so that i'm hyper aware
of it because otherwise i'm just living
at such a pace that i will tend to uh
which is a gift and a curse forget about
a lot of things from the past you know
so well and we'll talk about that a
little later that's why you bought a
time machine yeah so you can go back and
remember those moments wait i want to
ask you something though you were saying
that you kept moving forward with
skateboarding because you were getting
the validation whether it was just the
sponsorships or a thousand dollars to
move out here if you didn't get that
validation do you think you would have
continued
skateboarding it wasn't just something
that you wanted to do regardless of what
happened well i think it's still it's
the passion your goal is to become a
professional skateboarder right there's
sort of these steps that have to happen
right you have to be validated by a
skate shop i got sponsored by the skate
shop then you need to be validated by a
factory company and be sponsored by a
factory company then you've got to
perform in contests and then they have
to eventually invite you to turn pro
right that's sort of the process so if
you can imagine all that happened
between
age 11 and 16
and if somewhere along that way along
that route like even though this is my
dream and my passion
like would i have continued doing it if
i if i didn't get it validated like i
don't know it's hard to say because
you're in ohio you feel the pressure of
like oh you should go to school you
gotta like you gotta like build an
education you gotta figure out what your
career is you know i was still i like to
say i grew up in a fixed mindset
household with a fixed mindset uh went
to a fixed mindset school it was fixed
mindset parents where it's like you have
one route to like find a successful life
and you have to break out of that when
you're a young child you know
but or or not yeah or
or like be in ohio making my mom so
happy
that i'm like you know but you could be
in ohio and have a great job as an
accountant there are people that are
satisfied with that and then i'm always
fascinated by the people who aren't
fascinated who aren't content i'm using
the wrong word who aren't content with
whatever that path is yeah so you broke
that path you're here and you're getting
a thousand dollars a month you're living
with four girls avoiding aids yeah
what's the next step
yeah i mean look i think at that point
it really began to accelerate because
when i got
i had lived in ohio up to that point and
i had built sort of a reputation but it
wasn't until i was in the epicenter of
the skate culture in in san diego
did i
did the industry sort of take note of
like wow this guy's really talented
let's steal him
from this company in ohio because i
turned pro for a company that was based
out of
uh informed in dayton ohio right so that
was a skateboard company and they you
know look you know to to believe it or
not was only the the the company that i
was sponsored by in gns in san diego the
guys who ran it moved back to dayton
ohio because there was a skateboarding
distribution company there and they
formed the alien workshop i helped name
it when i was 16 years old because of
the
project blue book of re-engineering
alien technology and little alien
workshops and hangar 18 in dayton ohio
is why we called it the alien workshop
and
that is who i turned pro for
and this small upstart startup uh in
dayton ohio and so when i got to
california all the big companies in in
california tried to buy me away who was
giving you a thousand dollars to move to
california alien workshop yeah they
committed to giving me a thousand and
why san diego i know tony hawk's from
san diego but i would think the
epicenter for uh skateboarding was
either venice or marina del rey yeah
i mean i think i think los angeles was a
little too spread out almost like all of
the core companies in skateboarding were
either in san francisco or in san diego
almost all of them
so it was much more even though la
eventually went on to like grow into
like a skate capital at that time it was
still san diego or san francisco really
it wasn't z boys and dog town stuff they
were like venice and said marina del rey
so if it was born here the industry
didn't grow here the same way right like
for some reason for whatever reason and
it's funny like even as you question me
right now i'm like why is this
how did that happen they invented it in
venice
but yeah like for whatever reason i i i
just think as you got it's it's the type
of people that were involved in it
um tended to kind of clump together and
it's a very skater owned and driven sort
of world where
the actual skaters went connected with
business people and built skateboard
companies in the early industry and i
think because they were all in the same
area
they kind of helped each other if you
will i think that's why san diego
specifically got so big
[Music]